[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
solide face aux territoires sur tv5monde
en direct avec nos partenaires vous le
savez ouest france d'ailleurs regardé
cette émission sur ces sites ouest
france.fr sur nicematin.com par contre
sur franceantilles.fr sur lamontagne.fr
est en reprise sur 20minutes.fr mon
invité ce matin bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous c'est michel barnier bonjour
bonjour michel barnier on jouera tous
les téléspectateurs de l'échappement de
outremer à l'étranger diffusé dans 200
pays et en 14 langues vous êtes
d'ailleurs l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères vous avez vu
d'ailleurs la tutelle de cette chaîne il
ya quelques années vous êtes également
ex commissaire européen on vous connaît
aussi pour avoir négocié le bras exit et
vous êtes auteur de la grande illusion
chez gallimard un livre qu'on va voir et
on en reparlera bien sûr pendant cette
émission littéraire d'ailleurs je le
dire pas changé depuis quelques jours
livre de poche soit lâché chez folio
gallimard vous faites bien michel
barnier l'actualité évidemment c'est
cette guerre en ukraine 15e jour de
cette guerre en ukraine avec un sommet à
versailles 27 chefs d'état sont attendus
pendant deux jours quels résultats
peut-on attendre concrètement de ce
sommet à versailles est-ce que c'est au
fond s'unir contre la guerre ce que tous
doivent s'unir contre la guerre ou
est-ce que c'est déjà fait ça c'était
tapé passé et on va passer aux
discussions très concrète par exemple
sur l'indépendance énergétique
s'unir pour la paix et s'unir pour
l'europe et c'est la responsabilité des
27 chefs d'états de leur président
charles michel qui va présider cette
réunion du conseil européen ce sont les
27 chefs d'état que je connais bien
puisque c'est avec eux et en leur nom
que je négocie le break site pendant
quatre ans et demi il peut sortir
quelque chose de weir et manquerait de
cette réunion évidemment qu'il va sortir
des décisions confirmant les sanctions
qui s'accroissent et qui s'aggrave
contre pouvoir russe et tous ceux qui le
soutiennent dans cette guerre
épouvantable
une décision importante qui va être
prises c'est quel degré de dépendance on
on veut
préserver vis-à-vis de la russie à
propos du gaz et du pétrole devraient
venir la commission européenne proposait
mesure très importante ça il faut voir
où où les chefs d'état vont mettre le
curseur si je puis dire et puis aussi le
soutien la solidarité qui est la marque
même de l'union européenne avec
notamment les pays la pologne et
d'autres qui accueille la roumanie qui
accueillent les réfugiés en très grand
nombre actuellement une question très
rapide votre réponse là dessus trois
morts dont une fillette à marioupol
cette nuit la ville l'objet d'un blocus
ce qui se passe en ukraine ça
s'apparente à un crime contre l'humanité
ou pas ça vaut une guerre provoque
toujours des drames on voit ça à
mariupol bombardements absolument à
semer encore la qualification et de
poursuites pénales possible la justice
dira cela la justice internationale je
pense qu'elle va se ressaisir s'il ne
l'a pas déjà fait de ce qui se passe en
ukraine mais le bombardement
systématique d'immeubles de personnes
civiles contrevient aux engagements pris
par monsieur poutine on voit qu'il y à
des bombardements de maisons d'immeubles
d'hôpitaux en hôpitaux pédiatriques
hier tout cela est absolument
épouvantable et doit être qualifié je
pense en tout cas il faut arrêter ce
massacre l'hôtesse qualifier cette
rencontre métier je sais pas moi de le
dire mais je pense que ça s'apparente
vraiment un crime aux plaintes et merci
michel dernier notre avis tv on s'est
mis des affaires étrangères et ancien
commissaire européen bien sûr françois
xavier le front de ouest france sur ce
plateau dans un instant
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier l'offrant jour
leur chef de ouest france le plus grand
quotidien francophone du monde l'europe
de la défense bien sûr oui bonjour
monsieur barnier jour deux semaines
l'europe a changé elle n'est plus la
même et on prend conscience que la
question de la défense si on l'avait
oublié est une question majeure je
rappelle que vous êtes un spécialiste
des questions de défense européenne vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur ces sujets
et vous avez pendant de nombreuses
années
dit répété qu'il fallait mutualiser les
efforts de défense je crois c'est en
2016 vous rappeliez qui avait à l'époque
six pays qui fabriquait des frégates qui
fabriquait je crois 23 hélicoptères
différents est-ce qu'on n'a pas pris du
retard finalement sur la question de la
défense européenne ça se pose crûment
aujourd'hui
on voit bien que c'est l'enjeu de cette
guerre d'une des leçons de cette guerre
que de renforcer notre propre sécurité
parce que ce que nous ne ferons pas pour
nous sur notre continent la peau de gens
qui viendront le faire de l'extérieur à
notre place à nous sommes dans une
alliance quand on parle de défense en
europe il faut toujours rappeler que la
plupart des pays pas tous il ya
plusieurs pays européens qui ne sont du
pays neutre
l'irlande l'autriche la finlande la
suède même s'ils sont engagés dans des
opérations militaires ne sont pas dans
l'otan
donc il faut préserver cette alliance
est bonne intelligence même si nous
avons eu des déceptions dans le passé je
pense à la faire des sous marins
australiens et oui il faut tirer les
leçons et la leçon c'est qu'il faut
mutualiser davantage il ya une bonne
nouvelle bon état d'esprit actuellement
nouveau on le voit au danemark on le
voit en suède et en finlande ont voire
d'allemagne où l'allemagne viennent
décidé une augmentation considérable 60
gr 100 milliards de sans doute d'abord
pour remettre à niveau à boult verts et
de l'équipement national de l'armée
allemande mais aussi pour participer à
un effort commun alors la question c'est
y compris pour nous où nous devrons
c'est d'ailleurs ce que proposent-ils
pécresse augmenter encore le budget
national de la défense la loi de
programmation
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces efforts
nationaux est-ce que c'est chacun pour
soi dans son couloir ou bien est-ce
qu'on mutualisent davantage dans des
opérations extérieures quand y en a
besoin et dans des programmes de
recherche et des programmes de
développement de matériel on sait où il
faut faire porter l'effort sur le
spatial
sur la lutte contre
les attaques cyber et puis sur des
matériels structurants comme les avions
gros porteurs par exemple est-ce que la
solution c'est une armée européenne
je ne crois pas à ce mot il faut se
méfier des incantations monsieur macron
l'a utilisé comme d'ailleurs et il a
fait je trouve beaucoup d'incantations
depuis cinq ans ou se méfier de toute
diplomatie velléitaire soyons pratique
on doit mutualiser être capable de
projeter à l'extérieur comme on l'a pas
fait depuis quelques années des troupes
en commun il faut mutualiser aussi la
recherche et la fabrication de chars
d'avions de chasse de paris de corvette
ou deux frégates il faut absolument
qu'on mutualisent davantage et donc une
partie de cet effort national qui va
être augmentée dans chaque pays doit
être mise en commun et là il ya les
outils dans le traité il ya la
coopération structurée que j'avais
d'ailleurs proposé dans la fameuse
constitution européenne il ya la clause
de solidarité qui montre bien que nous
ne sommes pas seulement un supermarché
il ya le rôle du haut représentant
il ya plein d'outils dans la haie et
puis pour la première fois il ya un
budget européen le budget de l'union
européenne est utilisé pour la défense
pour la première fois depuis 60 ans dias
a fait 9 milliard je pense qu'on
pourrait facilement doubler cet effort
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
l'alliance de l'otan si demain donald
trump était réélu c'est un scénario qui
n'est évidemment bon mais qui est tout à
fait envisageable on se dit est ce que
l'europe ne doit pas anticiper sa
défense sans les américains se dire que
demain elle aura sans doute à se
défendre peut être sans les américains
sans l'otan mais on se souvient tous de
ce qu'a dit monsieur 30 sur l'otan je
m'accroche d'ailleurs a dit des choses
aussi assez imprudente à ce sujet il ya
quelques années et ça provoque est
d'ailleurs de tous les pays européens
qui en état de mort clinique vous faites
allusion à ce qu'avaient dit les
présents de rage un peu imprudente et à
l'emporte-pièce qui a provoqué
immédiatement de tous les pays européens
qui sont très attachés à l'alliance
atlantique recul en matière de défense
européenne donc méfiant doute je pense
qu'il faut préserver ce cadre européen
avec monsieur trump un jour
éventuellement week le tube hayden parce
que les américains peuvent pas faire
face tout seul au défi aux ans au danger
du monde ils ont besoin d'un pilier
européen et ce pilier il faut qu'ils
soient à la fois autonome et solidaire
sont deux mots d'ailleurs qui sont je
n'ai pas inventé ce sont deux mots qui
sont dans une déclaration dite
déclaration de saint malo signé entre
jacques chirac à l'époque et tony blair
et je reste sur cette idée que la
défense européenne doit être autonome
elle ne l'est pas encore et solidaire
quand il le faut dans l'otan alors le
chef d'état major français le général
burkhard disait en 2021 c'est à peu près
un an il disait la france elle ne doit
arrêter de croire qu'il vit dans une
bulle les menaces régionales vont
s'amplifier elles sont très importantes
et ses propos résonnent évidemment
particulièrement aujourd'hui est ce que
les français chaque citoyen français ne
doit pas quand même s'interroger sur la
question de la défense qui est une
question très lointaine dans la société
aujourd'hui finalement l'impression que
ça ne concerne pas trop et là chacun se
dit mais si demain j'ai avec moi à
défendre mon pays
écoutez la défense nationale
des vins de souveraineté territoriale
c'est le coeur des missions du nouveau p
du prochain de la prochaine présidente
de la république française des jeux je
regrette qu'on ait besoin de cette
guerre pour en parler parce que dans un
débat présidentiel on doit parler de
tout dire c'est pourquoi il faut un vrai
débat et que les français ne doit pas se
voir voler le débat présentiel comme
monsieur mac on voudrait le confisquer
ou ou l'éluder mais à coup sûr il faut
qu'on comprenne pourquoi on fait un
effort national on doit augmenter notre
effort de défense nationale nous avons
une armée professionnelle maintenant
mais il ya aussi plein de réservistes
auquel il faut rendre hommage et je
pense que ce débat doit être au coeur du
département est ce qu'il faut relancer
redévelopper plus les la réserve est-ce
qu'il faut recréer un service militaire
ou sur les favorable à ça moi j'avais
proposé cela dans le débat de la
primaire vous en souvenez avec l'idée de
mobiliser d'avantagé de recréer un
consensus ou un lien national nous
attachons une appropriation de 2 du
sentiment national qui qui s'est
beaucoup diluée on va pas ouvrir ce
débat maintenant mais en tout cas
renforcé comme madame pécresse l'a
proposé à travers la loi de
programmation dans les dix et quinze ans
qui viennent renforcer les fonds on voit
bien que ce que nous ne ferons pas pour
nous français d'autres deviendront pas
le faire une place ce que nous ne ferons
pas pour nous européens percevra le
faire notre place michel barnier est
notre invité l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères chaunu qui est
dessinateur et collaborateurs
ouest-france à une question à vous poser
sous forme de dessin c'est la tradition
de cette émission on regarde ensemble
michel hormis l'europe est une belle
idée mais au fil des années elle est
devenue la belle au bois dormant
et il ya quelques jours bien ce n'est
pas de baiser langoureux un prince
charmant il l'a réveillé mais plutôt les
grognements dan ours mal léché alors la
question que je pose un grand
spécialiste des institutions européennes
est la suivante pourquoi l'allemagne qui
est en train de reconstituer son armée
très fertelle les f16 américain au
rafale français à moins que les 50 états
qui constituent la nation américaine
mais bien face maintenant partie
intégrante
de l'union européenne
c'est pas le premier pays européen qui
achète du matériel américain et les
américains sont très actifs que je
disais que telle réponse à votre
question c'est que c'était fort de
coopération de mutualisation doit
évidemment porté à qualité égale de
matériel sur la l'achat de matériel au
cap et à la défense de l'industrie
européenne c'est le cas c'est pas
toujours le cas on le voit bien donc il
faut aller dans ce sens là mais
globalement si on utilise les budgets
nationaux et le budget européen pour
favoriser des programmes de recherche du
prof de matériel européen ce sont ces
matériels qui doit faire l'objet d'une
préférence européenne ce qui veut dire
que les pays européens doivent s'engager
progressivement à acheter ou à n'acheter
que d'abord européen maintenant je vais
juste un mot du contexte dans lequel
nous travaillons avec des crises
successives c'est pas la première crise
donc que nous subissons niveau européen
je veux rappeler la crise financière
2007/2008 qui a provoqué des millions de
destructions d'emplois le bris site que
je gérais qui est un échec de l'union
européenne locaux vides qui a arrêté qui
a provoqué beaucoup de solitude beaucoup
de morts beaucoup de maladies beaucoup
de chômage et puis cette guerre et
quelques on constate chaque fois à
chacune de ces crises c'est que les
européens ont réagi ensemble et ont pris
les bonnes décisions passage d'espoir
dans cette constatation est gelée vu de
très près dans deux de ces crises la
crise financière est-ce que j'ai eu à
reconstruire la régulation financière
comme commissaire européen et la crise
du précipice que j'étais négociateurs et
là j'ai vu l'unité le dos au mur et puis
on rebondit on prend de bonnes décisions
vos équipes françois-xavier le franc à
la frontière où il ya la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la pologne et la une ce
matin elle est consacrée donc à ce défi
pour l'europe le défi sur les questions
de défense le défi aussi sur la question
de l'indépendance énergétique
françois-xavier lefranc rédacteur en
chef de ouest france dans un instant
denis carot directeur des rédactions de
nice-matin nous rejoint sur sa plate
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot merci nous avant que
vous preniez la parole nous allons
partir pour les antilles à fort de
france c'est aussi une des traditions de
cette émission le directeur éditorial de
france antilles à une question à vous
poser michel barnier sur le nouvel ordre
géopolitique
bonjour michel barnier vu depuis les
outre-mer en tout cas ici aux antilles
ou en guyane le conflit craignant peut
paraître lointain en tout cas éloignée
des préoccupations de la population
pourtant c'est bien un nouvel ordre
géopolitique qui se dessine et qui se
dessinera l'issue de ce conflit qu'elle
pourra peut-être la place
occupée par les outre-mer sur cette
nouvelle carte du monde post conflit
je suis très attaché à notre département
un territoire d'outre-mer qui nous
permettent d'être présent grâce à nos
compatriotes
dans tous les océans du monde et c'est
une position géopolitique comme vous le
dites vous même qui dans laquelle il
faut s'appuyer quand on parle de la
grandeur de notre pays c'est pas
seulement un mot général de gaulle is
est un grand pays est un pays qui le
veut nous le voulons et donc nous avons
des atouts notre siège au conseil de
sécurité qu'on va pas partagé mais qu'on
va utiliser au service de la paix
les trois millions et demi de français
qui vivent à l'étranger qui travaillent
qui porte une partie de l'influencé de
l'image d'autres pays et qui sont
parfois dans les pays dangereux et puis
nos outre-mer la france de l'outre-mer
qui fait partie de destin national donc
je pense en effet que quand on parle des
antilles et vous parliez martinique et
guadeloupe mais aussi la guyane
navigateur les conséquences de cette
guerre et le retrait de la russie avec
soyouz et puis quand on parle de la zone
asie pacifique avec la réunion ou
territoires du pacifique on voit bien
qu'on a une carte à jouer moi je
voudrais simplement content qu'on
utilise cette carte pas seulement pour
nous français pour nous d'abord français
avec nos compatriotes d'outre-mer mais
aussi avec l'union européenne lundi
carreau bonjour michel barnier le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire a
estimé hier que la crise dans laquelle
nous sommes entrés aura des effets
comparables au choc pétrolier de 1973
alors michel barnier que faut-il faire
que peut-on faire pour limiter au
maximum l'impact de l'explosion des prix
dans la vie quotidienne des français
il ya des mesures immédiates qu'on doit
prendre de mon point de vue celles qui
ont été prises pour bloquer les prix
l'augmentation des prix du gaz ou de
l'électricité
s'agissant du de les chances puisque
c'est une partie du sujet aujourd'hui
dans l'urgence je pense qu'il faudrait
plafonner
leurs revenus des taxes que touche
l'état il n'y a aucune raison que l'état
saint-régis quand tu es français c'est
ça le gouvernement s'y refuse il a il a
tort je viens de vous dire il s'agit pas
de supprimer les taxes il s'agit de
constater que en raison de
l'augmentation du prix du baril et donc
chez nous pour chaque français du prix
du litre de fioul ou d'essence les taxes
augmentent et que l'état s'enrichit
mécaniquement quand les français
s'appauvrissent donc je propose je pense
à titre personnel je dis bien à titre
personnel qu'il faudrait limiter leur
venue au plafond atteint peut-être il ya
huit ou dix jours pour que cette double
phénomène de régis mans de l'état
d'enrichissement de l'état
d'approvisionnement des français ne
continue pas après il ya des mesures
dont il va être question de villiers
vous en parler au conseil des chefs
d'état tout à l'heure à versailles c'est
comment on est moins dépendant il n'y a
pas 36 solutions il faut diversifier nos
approvisionnements ne pas dépendre comme
on l'est aujourd'hui surtout l'allemagne
autant du gaz et du pétrole russes
comment on peut faire concrètement et
dans quel calendrier parce qu'on voit
que la commission européenne va proposer
des mesures aujourd'hui extrêmement
ambitieux de réduire de deux tiers de
dépendances en quelques mois est-ce que
c'est réaliste oui je pense là où il ya
un chemin là où il ya une volonté il ya
un chemin de réduire des deux tiers
d'ici la fin de l'année ça semblait
noter cela prendra quelques mois de plus
mais il faut faire cet effort et même
sens
l'urgence de cette guerre épouvantable
on doit diminuer notre dépendance on le
fait comment en diversifiant nos
approvisionnements vers la norvège ou
vers l'algérie où d'autres pays du golfe
en consommant moins c'est à dire les
économies d'énergie
l'isolation des bâtiments privés et
publics il ya énormément de réserve
d'efficacité énergétique et puis en
continuant à produire de l'énergie
nucléaire vous me permettez de le dire
puisque on est en campagne
présidentielle j'aimerais bien qu'un
jour on est sur tv5 monde mais aussi
dans le pays un vrai débat que le
pouvoir esquiver
voilà sept ou huit ans comprend pas les
bonnes décisions d'autres pays que le
pouvoir actuel monsieur macron
particulier à tergiverser n'a pas pris
les bonnes des chiffres au matin il
regarde la réalité il dit il faut
relancer le nucléaire mais pourquoi ne
l'at il pas fait depuis cinq ans on a
perdu beaucoup de temps et là nous
sommes au coeur de votre question qui
suit la dépendance énergétique de notre
pays le président ukrainien volodimir
résidence qui estime que
l'europe finance la guerre de poutine
quand ils achètent du gaz à la russie
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas d'ores et
déjà en france arrêtez d'acheter du gaz
russe c'est une question qui est posée
moi je suis assez favorable à ce que en
parallèle à ce que viennent de citer les
américains mais qui dépendent moins de
lait produits pétroliers énergétiques
russes comprennent des mesures très
fortes c'est une des questions qui va
être tranché je pensais aujourd'hui voir
on met le curseur si on supprime
totalement les approvisionnements ou si
on les diminue fortement et en toute
hypothèse
avec cette guerre en plus je pense qu'il
faut réduire notre dépendance à la
russie vous avez l'air de dire que c'est
assez d'accord avec bruno le maire sur
ces sujets qui s'est exprimé là dessus
oui enfin pour nous le maire et des
démos qui est imprudent l'autre jour en
parlant de guerre économique vous faire
attention aux mots la dépendance
énergétique je pense mais vous êtes se
réunira attendu bruno le maire pour dire
que dans quelques sujets légers même
écrit un livre en 2014 sur cette
question qui ce qui saperait se reposer
ou être libre comment les européens sont
ils libres c'est-à-dire indépendants ne
dépendent pas des autres dans quelques
domaines notamment celui du numérique
celui des sacs et des actifs
stratégiques industriels celui de la
population celui de la politique
étrangère de la défense et celui des
énergies c'est en travaillant ensemble
et en construisant un vrai marché unique
de l'énergie c'est ça le sujet alors
après la crise énergétique on pourrait
être confrontée à une crise alimentaire
majeure l'envolée des prix du blé
notamment et les risques de pénurie vont
rapidement mettre certains pays en
grande difficulté
est ce que vous redoutez 7 cette crise
qui pourrait suivre la crise énergétique
les trois grands défis pour l'union
européenne pour les chefs d'état qui se
réunissait
plus de coopération et souveraineté en
matière de défense ce que j'appelle des
souverainetés nationales solidaire en
matière de défense
l'indépendance énergétique non parler et
puis l'autonomie alimentaire - pourquoi
je gens là aussi il ya des mesures
conjoncturelles il faut que le
gouvernement il va le faire je crois que
monsieur castex irréfléchie comment
soutenir les agriculteurs à la fois pour
céréales dont ils ont besoin puis
l'alimentation animale tout ça c'est
râpé recrute dans les prix à la
consommation
et puis et puis stratégiquement ne plus
accepter comme on est en train de dire à
bruxelles la décroissance agricole moi
je pense qu'il faut polluer moins
partout y compris en agriculture et on
peut polluer moins mais on peut on doit
produire plus et c'est possible avec de
la recherche de produire plus et de
polluer moins et donc je m'oppose et
madame pécresse aussi à toute forme de
décroissance de la production d'école
nous devons rester un grand pays et
l'union européenne un continent organisé
pour produire davantage la une de var
matin qui est un des journées du groupe
nice matin la une de var-matin vertige à
la pompe on vient d'en parler à la fois
le constat est l'analyse le décryptage
des experts à ce sujet denis carot
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin merci à vous on garde michel
barnier ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères ancien commissaire européen
avec nous armelle le goff directrice de
la rédaction de 20 minutes et sur ce
plateau dans un instant
[Musique]
bonjour armelle le goff merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant vous allez
poser les questions à michel barnier
mais notre partenaire de centre france
le journaliste du populaire du centre
cette fois ci sébastien du poids à une
question à poser depuis limoges à michel
barnier sur les prix qui vont sans doute
monter en europe michel varnier bonjour
vous avez été commissaire européen au
marché intérieur
aujourd'hui la guerre en ukraine laisse
planer des menaces sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz en céréales
les prix explosent de manière assez
importante on remarque que les mille
mètres cubes de gaz dépassent les 3500 $
que le la tonne de blé a augmenté de
plus de 50% à plus de 400 euros la tonne
l'europe et la france peuvent elles
faire face sont elles des hôtels avoir
des difficultés d'approvisionnement et
quelles sont les solutions à mettre en
place pour que ses répercussions ne se
fasse pas sentir auprès de la population
on si on dit la vérité à ceux qui nous
écoutent y aura des répercussions si la
raréfaction des ressources et
augmentation des prix donc les mesures
d'urgence nous en avons parlé j'ajoute
parmi les mesures d'urgence et ça c'est
un sujet pour les européens d'augmenter
massivement les capacités de stockage
pour avoir des mois devant soi on a
quelques mois devant nous de stockage
mais je pense que l'une des leçons c'est
à la fois pour la production agricole
les céréales et pour l'énergie
d'augmenter massivement dans chacun des
27 pays de l'union européenne aux
capacités de stockage et puis nous
l'avons dit longuement réduire notre
dépendance
consommer moins c'est l'effort de chacun
non pas se chauffer moins bien mais ne
pas dépenser d'énergie parce que les
maisons ne sont pas bien isolé je dis
cela parce que ça touche beaucoup
médéric lancé les territoires les
français les plus modestes je pense même
qu'il faudrait quasiment payer le
l'isolation thermique et le bruit aussi
en passant des logements des familles
les plus modestes consommer moins tout
ce qu'on peut comme économie produire
plus se nomme l'énergie nucléaire sur
lequel le pouvoir actuel a été fautif et
puis dépendre moins diversifié nos au
prochain provisionnement avec la crise
migratoire oui parce que cette guerre
c'est aussi une crise migratoire avec
aujourd'hui 2 millions d'ukrainiens qui
ont quitté leur pays pourtant récemment
dans le cadre des débats pour la
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
au sein du parti et l'air vous avez dit
souhaiter un moratoire de 3 à 5 ans sur
l'immigration dans l'union européenne
alors j'imagine que cette position
n'aurait plus cours actuellement face à
cette crise évidemment nous nous étions
dans un autre débat à un autre moment où
il n'y avait pas assez de guerre et
cette menace
conflit en europe avec toutes ses
conséquences humaines et dans l'urgence
nous devons être à la hauteur de nos
droits de nos valeurs de ce qu'est la
république française et donc accueillir
les réfugiés qui d'ailleurs
pour la plupart d'entre eux ont eu
qu'une seule envie c'est de revenir
vivre normalement dans leur propre pays
quand la paix sera revenu donc il faut
être prêt à accueillir ça ça veut dire
aussi pour les pays européens une
solidarité je fais une promotion 2006
tard par exemple aujourd'hui on laisse
quand même la pologne par exemple en
première ligne la pologne je disais
toujours dans le cas de ces débats que
si on arrêtait pas elle si on mettait
pas un moratoire sur sur l'immigration
il y avait un risque de brick cite à
nouveau au sein de l'union européenne et
tout le monde évidemment penser à la
pologne là dessus comment on peut faire
pas seulement la charge jeudi
distinguons bien la situation est
extraordinairement grave dans lequel
nous sommes elle qu'il faut faire face
par la solidarité y compris à l'égard de
la pologne ou la roumanie qui sont en
première ligne j'utilise vos propres
mots parce qu'ils sont là à la frontière
bien mais la mecque avec elle raison
armés de l'osce et peut-il y avoir
d'autres break site duo crise vous avez
négocié drac site vous êtes bien placés
pour nous dire oui je pense qu'il faut
faire attention que des événements
improbables comme était improbable bref
ils se produisent je le décris de la
police dont vous avez parlé c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que l'europe change sur un
ensemble de sujets qu'elles soient moins
naïve à leurs échanges commerciaux
livrés à du jeu elle doit se fixer
justement pour éviter ce genre pour
éviter ce genre de parcours que l'europe
soit capable avec ses frontières
extérieures et la frontière en pologne
est la nôtre la frontière en grèce où
j'étais avec valérie pécresse l'autre
jour pour dialoguer que le premier
ministre monsieur minsutah qui sait
aller voir dans l'île de samos comment
on peut accueillir dignement mais
clairement des réfugiés ces fronts
sexuelle peut être contrôlé ça veut pas
dire que personne ne passe mais quand on
sait qui on accueille dans le cas précis
de l'ukraine on doit accueillir les
réfugiés ukrainien en pologne en
roumanie et dans tous les pays européens
peut-être d'ailleurs est davantage celui
rejeté
moi j'ai fait une proposition il ya
quelques années de d'une force
européenne de protection civile pour
mutualiser les secours en cas de
catastrophe naturelle du capteur
d'industriels ou de catastrophe humaine
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui on aurait
bien besoin d'une telle force
aujourd'hui dans la description dans
laquelle on est en effet avec 5000
ukrainien aujourd'hui accueillis en
france est-ce qu'on est à la hauteur en
france on sait bien qu'on va devoir
accueillir beaucoup plus d'ukrainiens
vous avez une estimation vous non j'ai
pas des steve assurent les chiffres
court mais ça dépend j'essaie de dire
continuer ou pas si monsieur poutine
continue à tuer les gens pour les
obliger à pas prendre la route donc il
faut être prêt à un effort massif et je
pense que si ses dires continue comme on
a le sentiment qu'elle va continuer
alors il faudra se préparer à accueillir
plus de gens ça pose une question vous
ne m'avez pas poser c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant pour arrêter cette
guerre épouvantable cette folie ce que
j'allais vous posez alors juste une
autre question entre temps des
associations ont déjà alerté sur les
risques de traite d'êtres humains et
justement vous parliez d'une force de
protection civile en cas de crise de ce
genre iliad il ya des femmes et des
enfants beaucoup qui émigrent depuis
l'ukraine comment on fait pour les
protéger au mieux au sein de l'union
européenne dans les pays je ne pense pas
si je suis bien informé que les femmes
qui partent avec leurs enfants sans
leurs maris puisque les maris grèce pour
défendre l'ukraine et leur pays et leur
patrie fassent l'objet de traite on sait
qu'il y à des trafics d'êtres humains
venant de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée ou d'afrique qu'il faut
combattre de manière impitoyable et là
de la même manière donc tout ça veut
dire un effort d'humanitaire de soutien
d' apporter la nourriture des secours
des médicaments d'accueillir les gens de
les accueillir comme on le voit dans
beaucoup de communes de france michel
vergnaud la photo derrière vous est-ce
que les opinions publiques derrière vous
juste pour en accepter ça longtemps
c'est ça la vraie question ce que vous
pose comme question amène ces précisions
au sujet est ce que ces taxes est
exactement ce qu'ils aient pas que c'est
la guerre mais les conséquences des
images valent mille mots dans ces cas-là
et l'usc où les gens vont accepter ça
envoyait bien l'effort de solidarité
dans des centaines de communes de france
on accueille des femmes des enfants en
les scolarisant et donc il faut
encourager remercier toutes ces communes
et toutes ces associations qui font ce
travail être prêts à faire davantage ni
compris dans l'action d'urgence comme je
les dis avec cette force européenne
qu'il faudrait créer ou renforcer de
protection civile et puis après il faut
arrêter la guerre il faut que monsieur
poutine reviendra la saison pour
l'instant les forces russes ne sont pas
entrées dans kiev mais est ce que vous
pensez qu'en france et en europe les
opinions publiques les nos concitoyens
vont pouvoir supporter que kiev vivent
ce qu'il se passe actuellement à kharkiv
ou mario pole mais ce n'est pas
supportable mais ne sommes pas maîtres
des décisions que prend monsieur poutine
il faut faire une pression maximale et
augmenter les sanctions pour qu'ils se
rendent compte que son intérêt c'est
d'arrêter le gab la nouvelle audi zone
c'est lorsque c'est nabeul c'est le
cessez le feu qu'il faut obtenir et dès
le cessez-le-feu obtenu manière durable
viendra à nouveau le temps de la
diplomatie qu'on aurait peut-être dû
mieux saisir en fin d'année dernière je
rappelle que les propositions russes ou
les exigences russes ont été présentés
le 17 décembre et que on a attendu le
mois de février pour aller discuter que
monsieur poutine je pense là encore
valérie pécresse avait fait des
propositions de une conférence sur la
sécurité en europe la nouvelle
architecture de sécurité ce plan là il
faudra le reprendre dès le cessez le feu
obtenu avec l'aide et la médiation la
vue de la chine d'israël de la turquie
mais aussi l'intervention de l'union
européenne justement une question plus
personnelle vous avez eu maille à partir
avec les acteurs de ce conflit vladimir
poutine sergueï lavrov qui rencontre
aujourd'hui le ministre des affaires
étrangères craignant en turquie comment
on négocie avec ces personnes là il faut
créer un rapport de force françois
hollande dit pareil que vous
plein de sujets j'ai vu aussi les
observations de france hollande sur du
conditions d'autres traits ou malik
qu'elle était très tardive je peux être
d'accord avec lui parce que nous avons
beaucoup travaillé avec monsieur
hollande comme gta iv avec monsieur
macron mai mais il faut créer un rapport
de force européen et occidental pour
faire comprendre à monsieur poutine
qu'il faut arrêter cette guerre qui n'a
rien à gagner et qu'on peut discuter de
tout après y compris de la non adhésion
de l'ukraine à l'otan qui n'est pas une
question taboue à mes yeux et qui doit
faire l'objet de protège d'abord revenus
crenn et ensuite on est on arrête cette
guerre on confirme à l'ukraine la
perspective européenne on dit aussi que
on peut très bien assurer la sécurité de
notre continent c'est l'objet du plan
que j'évoquais à travers cette
conférence sur la sécurité en europe en
garantie en garde l adhésion
immédiatement c'est sans adhésion sans
élargir le temps puisque c'est une des
conditions de lignes rouges de monsieur
poutine mais ça ne se discute pas dans
la guerre et en tuant des gens là une de
20 minutes par mail le goff je ne serais
pas étonné la une c'est sur la flambée
des prix et des carburants et les
conséquences que ça non seulement sur
nos concitoyens mais aussi sur le tissus
économique parce que ça a des
conséquences pour les entreprises pour
les pêcheurs pour tout un tas de métiers
merci armelle le goff qu'il dirige la
rédaction du journal 20 minutes michel
barny reste avec nous ce matin l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères est
l'invité de face aux territoires dans un
instant les questions internationales
avec des maîtres korkmaz et 2
[Musique]
voilà l'ukraine et l européenne
maintenant exactement est-ce que vous
pensez que la limite à l'est de l'europe
c'est l'ukraine
d'ukraine est clairement sur le
continent européen alors si vous parlez
de l'europe c'est différent de parler de
l'union européenne alors est ce que les
européens ont raison aujourd'hui
d'entamer des négociations d'adhésion en
2004 pour la turquie vous aviez dit
négociations d'adhésion ne vaut pas
adhésion il faut faire attention est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont raison pour
nous les gens de la turquie sur lequel
on avait en effet un autre moment et
dans un autre contexte avec un
gouvernement très différents qui a
beaucoup changé en moins à moins bien si
je puis dire en turquie du point de vue
des droits de la justice de la liberté
de la presse on avait ouvert des
négociations et j'avais dit ça veut pas
des ions ça peut durer très longtemps et
là je pense même qu'il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui il dira clairement turcs eux
que leur vocation n'est pas d'entrer
dans l'union européenne on doit avoir
une autre forme de partenariat mais
madame pic mais vous étiez plutôt
favorable vous allez pas qu'est-ce que
vous mais parce que les choses ont
changé quand on adhère c'est comme un
mariage il faut être deux il faut être
près des deux côtés
nous ne sommes pas prêts à élargir
immédiatement l'union européenne on voit
bien qu'il ya un problème à régler entre
nous d'abord et puis il faut que le pays
qui va dire est soit après la turquie
n'est plus prête et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elles le souhaitent encore en tout
cas elle s'est mis en position de ne
plus être capable d'adhérer aux valeurs
aux droits fondamentaux au cahier des
charges l'union européenne sans
fondement que michel barnier le pouvoir
et je voudrais juste répondre à mon
mandat soit vous êtes très très très
tellement impliqué vous êtes presque en
fonction non support fonction jeu
j'étais dans une fonction très difficile
et très exigeante qui était celle de
négociateurs l'union européenne on a
bien conclu cet accord à condition que
monsieur johnson le respect des savanes
en jour le cas
je suis dans l'action c'est pour ça que
j'étais le candidat la présence de
république dans la primaire est
aujourd'hui compte tenu du résultat des
militants je suis prêt et je pense que
nous devons tout faire pour qu'elle voie
à la première femme présidente de la
république française parce qu'elle a la
capacité elle est à la hauteur
l'expérience pour cela je suis convaincu
de cela mais je pense aux amis centre de
l'ukraine de la moldavie la géorgie il
faut pas faire de promesses qu'on ne
tiendrait pas faut pas créer des
déceptions à l'avance je pense qu'il
faut préserver ou confirmer la vocation
européenne de ces pays je rappelle qu'on
a négocié avec l'ukraine un accord
d'association extrêmement ambitieux qui
n'a que quelques années confortant le
consolidons le faisons le vivre évaluant
la situation n'est en tout cas oui je
pense qu'il faut confirmer à l'ukraine
sa vocation européenne sa vocation
européenne mais pas de pas de promesses
pas de promesses qu'on ne serait pas
capable de tenir il faut respecter les
gens et les respecte et ça veut dire ne
pas leur promettre n'importe quoi en
revanche les aider maintenant dans
l'urgence à retrouver la stabilité et la
paix à reconstruire leur état et quand
partie du pays qui a été détruit par les
russes à travailler avec nous à la
stabilité du continent européen et avec
les russes obtenir des garanties
définitive et durable et puis leur
confirmer leur la perspective de
participer au projet européen alors on
voit que le conflit en ukraine drogba un
peu les cartes de la géopolitique
washington opère un rapprochement avec
caracas avec l'iran aussi peut-être on
est en train de renégocier ou en tout
cas d'arrivée peut-être à un accord sur
le nucléaire qui permettrait de lever
les sanctions et donc de nouveaux
exporter de l'iran pour être de nouveau
exporter son pétrole est-ce que comment
vous voyez ce cette géopolitique qui se
mouvant en ce moment il ya une chose
dont je suis sûr c'est dans cette
géopolitique qui bouge il faut que les
européens pas d'une seule voix vis-à-vis
des américains vis-à-vis des chinois ou
de la russie si vous regardez
le g10 les 10 pays les plus importants
du monde dans les 30 ans qui viennent il
ya encore aujourd'hui quatre pays
européens dans le g10 allemagne royaume
uni france italie et tous les dix ans 4
qui est éjecté du tableau et a besoin de
moi quand même c'est la question si on
va s'il admire ou pas est-ce qu'on va
s'y maintenir et 2050 il ya plus que
l'allemagne si nous sommes seuls dans
nos frontières nationales si nous sommes
ensemble nous restons à la table de ceux
qui vont organiser l'ordre des heures du
mans ma première réponse est celle là il
faut être européen en plus d'être
patriote européen et patriote patriote
et européen ça c'est ma devise est celle
de valérie pécresse après l'iran moi
j'étais mise affaires étrangères j'ai
participé aux négociations et cliron
avec les états unis avec l'angleterre
pour obtenir cet accord que monsieur
tron pas
ensuite ont renoncé à appliquer et qu'on
était en train de remettre sur la table
c'est une bonne nouvelle si
l'iran accepte de ne pas aller vers
l'armement nucléaire dans le nouvel
accord qui est en discussion
actuellement que les russes essaient de
prendre en otage d'ailleurs en ce moment
même j'espère qu'on aboutir à un accord
dans les prochains jours à genève hug il
y à aussi je voudrais revenir sur la
question des sanctions est ce qu'il n'y
aurait pas des effets délétères
a par exemple gelé les réserves de la
banque centrale russe qui pourrait petit
à petit se tourner vers la chine et
peut-être que cette la dédollarisation
d'autres systèmes bancaires ailleurs
dans l'eau encore une fois nous sommes
dans dans l'urgence de mesures qui
doivent être fortes parce qu'en face de
nous on a un pouvoir russe qui bombarde
qui tuent des civils et qui ont envahi
un pays contre toute logique et contre
le droit international donc ces mesures
là elles ont pas destiné à être
définitive vous n'empêcherez pas les
russes de tourner vers la chinois s'ils
pensent que c'est leur intérêt guerre ou
pas gay en revanche les mesures qui sont
prises doivent être suffisamment claire
forte et puissante pour faire reculer le
pouvoir et le faire arrêter cette guerre
michel barnier vous c'est que nous
sommes diffusés dans le monde entier
dans 200 pays en 14 langues vous allez
vous avez essayé de tenter de convaincre
les français vivant en espagne à
quelques jours j'ai vu des images de
vous pour valérie de voter pour valérie
pécresse vous allez aux états unis je
crois à la fin du mois
et ce soit en belgique vous êtes très
actif pour valérie pécresse comme ça
pour convaincre les français de
l'étranger de voter pour elle c'est
important oui parce que je pense qu'il
faut changer en france il faut une
nouvelle donne il faut une respiration
d'abord il faudrait une vraie campagne
je trouve très grave je vous dis comme
je pense que le pouvoir prouve comme
mode de d'esquiver le débat présidentiel
que monsieur mâcon tu cherches à ne pas
faire face à sonde à son bilan parce que
ça fait cinq ans qu'ils gouvernent le
pays quand vous prenez les problèmes un
par un la sécurité des banlieues où il a
découvert les problèmes alors qu'il
gouverne depuis cinq ans l'énergie ou le
relance prom nucléaire quoi il est si
haut pourquoi président de la république
et sio dans les sondages diane von
visibilité plus grande et plus forte
actuellement en raison de ce conflit et
qu'il est le chef de l'état en exercice
maintenant mais les gens là ne juge pas
le sanctionne pas au fond au delà des
sondages qui montent et qui baissent
d'evere monter ou baisser dans les temps
qui viennent on a droit à un vrai débat
et c'est l'intérêt du pays la voir cette
respiration démocratique je vous prie de
croire le rayo législatives qu'on a faim
de haut par citoyen d'hommes politiques
engagées section on n'échappe à ce débat
c'est le pouvoir réussi à esquiver ou à
désamorcer tout débat présidentiel sur
le bilan les légendes a tiré à travers
un troisième tour des élections
présidentielles wii ou la rue où la rue
les français phénomène gilet jaune à
nouveau
débat ils ont droit cette respiration
démocratique le pouvoir doit faire face
à son bilan j'ai parlé de banlieue
j'aime pas de l'énergie et dû nucléaire
qui a été stoppée contre toute logique
pendant les cinq ans passés le commerce
extérieur je ne joue pas en ce moment
avait des centaines de milliers de
français qui vivraient qu'il travaille
pour la france le plat plupart d'entre
eux et pour pour le commerce extérieur
c'est un effondré mais vous exécutez
michel barnier de pouvoir travailler que
emmanuel macron s'il était réélu à canal
2 par exemple je ne suis pas très
critique avec lui est ce que ça sera
possible dans quelques mois je si l'on
vous confie une mission de d'adhérer je
suis qui était à ce jeu passera dans le
nouveau quartier d'un pays n'a pas été
bien gérée il eu trop de l'incantation
trop de solitude parfois de l'arrogance
et français n'ont pas été respectés je
pense qu'il faut une nouvelle donne dans
ce pays je cherche pas être agressif
parce que je ne le suis pas on peut dire
les choses calmement mais je pense qu'il
faut une nouvelle donne et que la seule
alternative sérieuse dans ce pays
responsable c'est celle que porte
valérie pécresse et ils voient les
courriers aux trois questions à poser
différemment vous pourriez travailler
avec je vais le maquereau à nouveau la
question des gangs où l'avait fait
françois hollande vous l'avez faire
jouer je vais en a trahi et
ericsson et avec emmanuel macron mais je
viens de vous répondre et nous sommes à
la quelque semaines quatre semaines
d'une élection présidentielle où il
s'agit pour moi de provoquer un
changement dans ce pays et un changement
responsable et sérieux celui que pour
valérie pécresse mais personne d'autre
dans cette campagne présidentielle vous
avez été alors déçu certainement mais
surpris de ne pas avoir été en tête des
primaires des républicains dessus à coup
sûr les cartes vous êtes candidat comme
je l'étais sans avoir d'ailleurs de plan
de carrière le fait pour dédier à michel
barnier les formidables il est un peu
old fashion il prend le temps
d'expliquer les choses il ne va pas
assez vite vidalies des jeunes et que ça
c'est des crédits que vous avez entendu
c'est des choses vous avez des gens qui
ont un certain âge des cheveux blancs
monsieur viguier qui peut avoir des
villes haineux et puis vous avez des
visions très jeunes qui ont de vieilles
idées moi je ferai partie des gens qui
ont une expérience j'ai été toute ma vie
paris citoyen savoure à revendiquer
d'être old fashion saint-paul fashion je
veux tu as beaucoup à l'actualité je
pense avoir des idées assez neuve et
avoir toujours été un peu un coup
d'avancé compris sur les questions du
défi écologique où je me suis engagé où
je continue d'être engagée mais
perriand ces tutus aussi merci beaucoup
et c'était
ça sera utile pour être aux côtés mais
la situation présente de leur clavier ni
mans michel barnier notre mission sera
rediffusé bien sûr et vous le retrouvez
sur les sites de nos partenaires
ouest-france nice-matin france antilles
la montagne et 20 minutes voilà merci à
thierry barbeau dette qui a coordonné
cette émission qui en a assuré la
rédaction en chef il est le patron
également de télé 78 la chaîne des
yvelines qui va évidemment couvrir ce
sommet de versailles qui démarre pour
deux jours et cette chaîne le couvrir de
manière locale est fortement merci à
tous on se retrouve pour un prochain
face au directoire
la semaine prochaine c'est gérard
longuet que vous connaissez bien qui
sera notre invité l'ancien ministre de
la défense merci des maîtres comme
servant à tous
[Musique]